not only are you guys obviously
historical artists great discographies
uh but you guys are all Moguls within
your own right and like I mean some of
the biggest Moguls of music Snoop Dogg
is killing the crypto space he's just
killing everything with a bunch of
movies too yeah he on his movie So
speaking of movies cute Vision speaking
of locked in all of the liquor we're
drinking speaking of the big three the
Goon with the spoon Ice Cream come on
man uh what is you guys are you guys
like passing ideas around in terms of
just like business opportunities and
[ __ ] because I do feel like
you know there's there's this it's kind
of a very unicorn situation and not only
have historical artists but historical
businessmen in a group together without
a doubt you know we uh we started you
know not just a group we got a mount
Westmore LLC so it's a business and you
know we funnel great ideas into the
business you know when it's when it's
right we let everybody know this is
something that we should all attack that
as a group
um and do it
um but I know I know we all involved in
investment groups uh I get the hint hint
we should start the mount Westmore
Investment Group
real talk any uh new uh stuff coming
from u40 I feel like every other month
there's like a new product I can eat or
drink so since the pandemic I recorded
over 70 songs since the since I'm
talking about since we finished the
mountain Westmore album
because the grit don't quit but anyway
yeah I got a rule of thumb coming that's
that's my there's two albums oh rule of
thumb and I can I talked to Cuban I'm a
team player I don't know if it's
possible for you to not drop a double
album I know every time it's a double
album It's a triple album it's I think
you put an EP out during the pandemic
and I was surprised that you had an EP
and not like a full project right right
yeah no no EPS no more I did EPS when I
was young and I dropped one I dropped
one that I felt I needed to put out
because it was on my heart it was my
real assignment before they were saying
he understood the assignment
it was really my assignment to drop it
it was me as a little two-year-old kid
three-year-old kid
um standing standing in front of a
garbage can it was an EP but it was it
had some great songs on there and it was
a rule of thumbs next Ruth Thomas next
rule of thumb two two albums and I don't
know if I'm gonna drop them exactly at
the same time or a week apart but slaps
um I got a couple more
um uh features I need I need one I
already told Mount Westmore I'm taking
over this one song that I wanted and
they they agreed that I can have it so
I'm slapping that on there and then um
I mean it slaps I got features I got and
I'm on there holding my own so you
always have the features unlocked and
you always tapped in with the younger
generation always tapped in with the
younger generation you know and I ain't
no slacking in my Mac and my link was up
to par I'm not trying to be young I
ain't trying to be on I'm just trying to
have a happy medium well I'm right there
and I'm gassing and I'm ahead of my time
you know what I'm saying